according to the data on the internet
the world's cup has five kilos of gold
in it and according to my calculations
if it was solid all the way through it
would have somewhere between 70 and 80
kilos of gold in it that's as much as
the weight of quite a large adult and so
it must be Hollow
this month and the beginning of next
month is the World Cup in football
soccer to those of you who are not
familiar with this and this competition
takes place every four years and
involves all the countries in the world
that have got through all the
preliminary stages and the central
symbol of this competition is the trophy
and the trophy is chemically quite
interesting because the main component
is that's made of gold and everybody
gets excited when they hear about gold
gold is quite an unusual metal because
it's really very soft and you can't
actually make anything that's very
artistic out of pure gold well you could
make it but then it's so soft that
whenever people started handling it and
a little ruffly it would start bending a
bit like trying to make things out of
lead and so people add other metals to
the gold to make it tougher to make it
stronger and in general the more other
metals you add the stronger it gets
so with this big trophy if it was made
out of pure gold the first time the
footballer lifted it above his head it
would just Bend and this would not be a
fitting end to the competition though it
might be the end of the footballer
jewellers and those that trade in gold
have come up with a really strange scale
to indicate how pure the gold is they
measure the purity in a unit that is
called a carat in the scale pure gold is
counted as being 24 carat so if you had
half pure gold
it would be 12 carat and as a compromise
the World Cup is made of 18 carat gold
that means 75% of the metal is gold and
25% is something else Gold is also very
heavy you
one of the densest metals that there is
so there's some question whether the cup
is really made at a pure gold or solid
gold if you look at the descriptions on
Wikipedia and things like that
they say it's made from solid gold well
I think this means is that the metal
part is gold all the way through it
isn't that there's a thin layer of gold
and the rest is steel for example
however I think and I have no means of
going that perhaps the ball at the top
which is the world is probably hollow so
it's not solid and all the way through
in the sense that there's no space
because I don't think that it would be
light enough for people to wave about
their heads and also be big waste of goq
according to the data on the internet
the world's cup has five kilos of gold
in it and according to my calculations
if it was solid all the way through it
would have somewhere between 70 and 80
kilos of gold in it that's as much as
the weight of quite a large adult and so
it must be Hollow the gold cup is famous
for a second point that at the base it
has two stripes of green presumably to
represent the grass on the playing
fields these green bands are made from a
mineral called malachite and I've got
small sample here which comes from
Ireland and malachite is a copper
compound it's a mixture of its so-called
basic copper carbonate it contains
copper carbonate rather like in chalk
and also it contains OAH groups oxygen
and hydrogen and it's quite a common
mineral you can see I got this sample
from the souvenir shop in Ireland but it
is quite rare to get it in large pieces
as far as I'm aware malachite isn't used
for anything except decoration and it
looks really good and it's very
expensive but you can get quite a good
imitation of Alec mapa kite very cheaply
I visited Russia 40 years ago and stayed
in the cheap hotel and by the bed they
had what looked like malachite tables if
you looked at it it was chipboard
covered with a thin layer of green
plastic and it looked just the same but
I think on the World Cup they've got the
real malachite I'd be really upset to
discover it was plastic and chipboard
I'm not very interested in football I
was a teenager when England won the
World Cup in 1966 I didn't watch the
game then and I haven't watched the
World Cup get matched since then but
perhaps I will watch something this year
because I'm going on a trip to Italy
during the World Cup with Brady and my
colleagues and I'm sure they want to
watch